yeah but it's tiring like I'm not gonna  lie like even like I'm married and  happily married and everything but like  it's tiring just like my wife puts on  makeup or puts on a dress and if I don't  say anything like anything at all then  that's it a mood's ruined right so it's  like I have to comment because they've  made an effort but to me it's like I  don't care but is it maybe because you  didn't compliment her enough when you  guys were dating or but that that's what  I mean like it's like and guys just  don't express it as much maybe that I'm  thinking it in my head but I'm not gonna  say it like it's just but you're quick  to go and like someone like a girl's  picture on Instagram I mean I don't do  that so I can't speak for all guys  but I don't do that because I I just  find that